[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
22e numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi 28
février
ils sont de retour au cinéma depuis le
20 février avec le deuxième relais de
leur grande aventure
les lego sont aussi aux clayes-sous-bois
avec une exposition imaginée par des
passionnés il ne vous reste que quelques
jours pour entrer dans leur univers
le palais du roi de rome propose une
exposition pour expliquer les
réglementations urbaine et patrimoniale
de rambouillet plus belle ma ville offre
également des animations pour petits et
grands durant les vacances scolaires
le moulin du célèbre couple d'écrivains
se propose d'être l'espace créatif de
vos enfants
pour ces vacances d'hiver retrouver des
ateliers autour de l'exposition pierre
marie lejeune luc de saint phalle où les
4 à 12 ans un représentant de
l'établissement sera avec nous
le deuxième volet du film d'animation la
grande aventure lego est sorti en salles
le 20 février pour les retrouver en
plastique et en couleurs l'association
de passionnés de ces petites briques de
construction
breezy expose ses collections à l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
jusqu'au 3 mars visite au sein de l'art
de la brique visiter les plus grands
monuments du monde n'a géré entre les
poissons de cet aquarium tout en
couleurs
l'exposition légaux fait voyager
d'univers en univers ça travaille
quelques jours un peu plus lent que le
temps d'organiser de visiter la salle de
prévoir comment organiser
l'exposition trouver des oeuvres et pour
les amener toutes ses installations
proviennent des collections personnelles
de sept membres de l'association
yvelinoise brésis des passionnés de la
brique en plastique
parmi eux maxime est fier d'exposer pour
la première fois ses lego star wars
un jour j'ai fait un mix peau et puise
au prij atteint depuis longtemps
enfin on prend du temps
allez construire
et on prend du plaisir à les contrer si
les différents diorama font naître une
poussée de créativité l'association a
prévu un espace de construction où
l'imagination les talents d'architecte
l'écho s'exprime peu fait d'abord des
escaliers d'abord après jeu avant de
retrouver le monde réel on n'oublie pas
de chercher des personnages intègre
glisser dans ce monument égyptiens nous
ne révélerons pas notre secret mais nous
en avons déjà trouvé quelques uns
[Musique]
et pour continuer de se montrer créatif
on part à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines la
maison elsa triolet aragon propose des
ateliers vacances avec nous en plateau
pierre colas bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes responsable
communication de l'établissement sous
moulin qui a tant inspiré le le couple
d'écrivains elsa triolet louis aragon et
source d'inspiration pour les enfants
pendant ses vacances avec un atelier
créatif
oui exactement on est très heureux de
pouvoir organiser un atelier autour de
l'exposition qu'on propose en ce moment
donc comme on l'a vu dans les images
c'était pierre marie lejeune une équipe
saint phalle c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement colorés et pleins de plein
de figure qui sont très reconnaissables
en plus con c'est niki de saint phalle
et ses fameux visage c'est et puis ces
épices et fontaine est là justement on a
joué sur les mobiles qu'on pouvait voir
aussi sur les miroirs pour retrouve
aussi beaucoup et pierre marie lejeune
d'un a proposé aux enfants de les
fabriquer avec nous donc voilà ils vont
quoi précisément ces enfants vous en
avez nous beaucoup ils sont il faut
s'inscrire on s'inscrit c'est un petit
peu par tranche d'âge en fait il ya des
activités différentes pour les enfants
de 4 à 7 ans puis de 8 à 12 ans et l'a
ensuite on découvre l'exposition
ensemble on dessine un petit peu les
formes qu'on a vu pour imiter un petit
peu niki de saint phalle pour essayer de
comprendre comment il faisait et après
ça on fabrique les cadres ou alors on
décore les miroirs en fonction de l'âge
alors si on revient sur cette exposition
s'est elle elle montre un peu la
collaboration qui a eu un entretien
marie lejeune et niki de saint phalle
passer d une colonne leur passion en
effet qui a duré très longtemps puisque
pierre maille j'ai d'abord été
l'assistant de niki de saint phalle
partir des années 80 il avait collaboré
avec elle sur la fontaine stravinsky à
paris par
et puis ensuite donc ils ont réalisé des
oeuvres ensemble qui s'affale aimait
beaucoup travailler à 4 mains avec
d'autres artistes
et là on reconnaît justement le travail
des deux là dedans est aussi un jeu un
plaisir qu'ils ont pris à réaliser ses
oeuvres ensemble placez votre votre
exposition d'ouverture de saison nous
avons fait beaucoup de monde
oui ça marche très bien ça a créé
beaucoup de visiteurs on est très
heureux que savait que ça démarre aussi
fort cette année et c'est ça aussi au
bio pour la suite puisqu'on aura deux
autres expositions tout au long de
l'année et on a on a la possibilité
d'accueillir donc des artistes comme ça
contemporains qui ont un certain renom à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et de pouvoir
les faire connaître aussi auprès du
public c'est très agréable pour tous
maintenant vous allez venez on l'a on
parle les activités pendant les vacances
scolaires mais la maison elsa triolet
aragon c'est toute l'année vous avez
toujours des expositions des activités
oui c'est une maison qui ne s'arrête pas
qui ce qui toujours justement travaux en
évolution et là-dessus bas en effet on
va avoir bientôt des spectacles qui vont
qui vont commencer à partir du 31 mars
on a proposé du jazz avec justement le
festival jazz à toute heure qui est donc
toute la vallée de chevreuse et après ça
on va proposer une chasse aux oeufs et
nous une journée d'étude autour du
journal d'aragon qu'est le les lettres
françaises
c'est donc on a toujours cette diversité
à l'intérieur de notre programme ça va
continuer comme ça jusqu'à jusqu'à fin
octobre
donc c'est pour ça que je pourrai pas
tout vous résumer il faut justement allé
voir de progression pour la première
action on a le site internet qui va
s'afficher donc juste on va parler les
prochains grands rendez vous en avez vos
quelques-uns oui ce qu'on pourrait dire
aussi c'est qu'on lance aussi des
ateliers pour les bacheliers
on se dit que justement révisé dans la
bibliothèque d'aragon ce serait très
bien pour quand vous devrez préparer le
bac français mais ça peut aussi se faire
pour le français pour le pour l'histoire
et pour les pour la philosophie et donc
ça aux vacances d'avril on proposera
aussi une session de révision là dessus
donc si vous voulez réviser votre bail
qui à la maison les intrus l'aragon peut
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site internet
merci pierre colas est venu sont aptes
ambiance beaucoup plus tôt l'ex cooking
l'eshop pratiquer votre anglais en
cuisinant c'est le principe des ateliers
proposés à versailles du 5 au 9 mars des
muffins aux tartes il en a pour tous les
goûts et tous les niveaux aux côtés de
la chaîne américaine teri molton vous
deviendrez de véritables cordons bleus
on continue dans le gustatif non plus
dans la langue de shakespeare mais dans
le dialecte scientifique la maison
théodore monod de guyancourt propose en
partenariat avec l'atelier des sciences
de saint quentin en yvelines une
exposition la science à du gouf du 4 au
10 mars vous pouvez retrouver un stage
scientifique chaque jour vos enfants
seront sensibilisés à la nutrition à
travers différents thèmes expliqué les
réglementations urbaine et patrimoniale
c'est l'objectif de l'exposition plus
belle ma ville au palais du roi du rhum
à rambouillet une présentation ludique
et tous et aussi interactif où durant
les vacances scolaires
zélie la petite souris demande de l'aide
aux enfants pour l'aider à construire sa
maison sans faire de bêtises
plusieurs visites animées ateliers sont
proposés pour les petits mais aussi pour
les plus grands de 8 à 14 ans les mardis
et mercredis et bien rouillier présente
l'objectif de cette exposition au micro
de mélanie poquet j'ai abordé très
technique
donc il a il a fallu le rendre attrayant
il est très austère de bassin
le texte lui même est quasi indigeste
pour un non spécialiste ce qui est
sûrement une grande difficulté
d'ailleurs pour la population mais c'est
le cas de la plupart des textes
réglementaires donc l'expo vraiment joue
la carte de la scénographie de la mise
en scène du ludique de l'expérimentation
et l'interactivité de façon à ce que
tout le monde puisse se retrouver et au
mois en repartir avec les idées
principales du cinéma jeune public dans
le cadre du festival télérama enfants
dont les yeux d'elsa et partenaires
c'est votre rendez-vous dans les selles
saint-quentinoise de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
retrouvez cette semaine au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa une programmation jeune
public qui s'inscrit dans un festival
dont on est partenaire cette année
encore qui est télérama enfants nous
organisons deux événements ce week end
samedi 2 et dimanche 3 mars
nous commencerons par une journée un
animations à 14 heures marie est la
fleur de la sorcière suivi à 16 heures
du dernier mamoru hosoda mirail ma
petite soeur et enfin pour la première
fois elle sur les écrans en france l'un
des premiers films de jeux d'hayao
miyazaki le château de cagliostro
ensuite dimanche 3 mars nous vous
proposerons une avant-première à 16h30
d'un très très joli film d'animation qui
s'appelle tito et les oiseaux réalisé
par gustavo steinberg
c'est un film d'animation brésilien
alors qui reprend une partie de la crise
politique que virile réside actuellement
alors ce n'est pas du tout un film à la
remise ou larmoyant mais il est quand
même question pour un groupe d'enfants
intrépides de sauver le monde et de
vaincre la peur qui finalement
un gang rennes le brésil et le monde
je suis immunisé contre la peur ce jour
là j'ai décidé que plus jamais je
n'aurais peur et que je prouverai que
mon père avait raison pour les oiseaux
[Musique]
plusieurs équipes encourager ce week-end
avec d'abord du basket le fc trappes
saint-quentin-en-yvelines affrontera
l'as des as
blois basket en nationale 3 pour la 17e
journée les trappistes ont actuellement
3e du classement dans ce championnat
très serré
ils n'ont que quatre points d'avancé sur
l'ad sur leurs adversaires dixième du
tableau mais aussi du football américain
dans le championnat de deuxième division
des templiers d'elancourt recevront ce
dimanche à 14h les gladiateurs de la
queue-en-brie pour le compte de la 5e
journée
victoire impérative pour les landes
courtois qui doivent se reprendre après
leur défaite 12 à 0 contre les vikings
de villeneuve d'ascq si vous voulez
assister au match
l'entrée est libre ou para taux de
vitesse direction le 19e arrondissement
de paris la cité des sciences et de
l'industrie accueille l'exposition
grande vitesse ferroviaire jusqu'au 18
août à travers des maquettes des jeux
interactifs et des simulateurs
les visiteurs sont invités à découvrir
les défis d'une astreinte striant
perpétuelle évolution
avec un seul but transporter les
voyageurs toujours plus vite
marc et maylis kerhoas de nos confrères
via grand paris a pris son billet
chaque année des millions de français
sont propulsés à 300 km heure sur les
rails la france détient depuis dix ans
le record du monde de vitesse avec une
pointe d'un tgv à 574 km heure sur 700
mètres carrés cette exposition retrace
l'évolution d'une industrie complexe de
la construction des lignes à la
circulation des trains le chemin de fer
à grande vitesse ressemble comme un
frère au chemin de fer classique
c'est un système c'est à dire qu'il est
composé d'éléments et ce qui est
intéressant ce sont les interfaces entre
ces éléments
et c'est justement ce que l'exposition
essaye de montrer et c'est là que il y à
des nouveautés le marché de la mobilité
va bouger et le train devra s'adapter
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
train a déjà plus de deux siècles
d'existence il ya vu des grands
bouleversements puisque il a dû
affronter la concurrence automobile il a
dû affronter la concurrence de l'avion
mais il est toujours là
il a toujours su se renouveler et il a
toujours su s'adapter s'adapter aux
nouvelles technologies c'est aussi ce
que cette exposition a tenté de faire
on peut alors s'essayer à la réalité
augmentée et utiliser des applications
numériques
un simulateur de trains grande vitesse
occupe d'ailleurs le centre de l'espace
de l'exposition par exemple nous avons
un bac à sable où il faut je dirais
aménager le terrain pour peu qu'une
ligne à grande vitesse puisque en place
et donc là on voit bien ce que c'est que
le nivellement du terrain
ce qu'auront les courbes etc on a aussi
l'expérience où on déplace un chariot ou
un wagon et on s'aperçoit que
l'adhérence du wagon fait que avec un
petit effort on va loin alors que un
camion le même effort ne permet pas de
couvrir la même distance
l'idée était d'apporter dans
l'exposition des éléments concrets comme
arai du ballast une caténaire etc
ces éléments sont indispensables pour
réaliser des performances au quotidien
favoriser la fiabilité la ponctualité ou
encore le confort des voyageurs et pour
ne pas rater le train cette exposition à
grande vitesse est à découvrir jusqu'au
18 août
et c'est la fin de ce vote recette
choisie remercie nous avoir suivi ce
dimanche 3d sans oublier 3 mars
n'oubliez pas la fête des grands mères
quant à moi je vous donne rendez vous
jeudi prochain bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
ouais
oh
faux